everyone hey guys Ryan right here I'm
Brianna white Brianna wine and I are
gonna watch the trailer right now for
the brothers Grimsby
it's called English yeah learn to speak
it Luke said that's the COPO let's adopt
a nose you are coming with me right now
they I've never lived
we've decided to adopt one of the
brothers mr. Leslie these boys are
inseparable it would break their hearts
so sure about sending you to Grayson
he's the best I ever trained
for 28 years I've been searching for me
baby brother
oh we're finally here brother
he's gonna be at this posse mates
tomorrow
finally I can make things right Nobby oh
my god of you my shop was compromised a
huge manhunt to find the rogue secret
agent stay away from me don't worry it's
bulletproof
you can't house we've got bulletproof
glass
that pellet was filled with the toxin
I'll be dead in 90 seconds you know suck
it suck it physically die okay what
would you like written on your
gravestone project and in what font
would you like that
bring me Sebastian graves
I lost it forever I'm useless you are
not useless it was a man who can get me
pregnant without even waking your baby
osa man was never even read a book me
the man works with me in a police
station without even getting arrested
that wasn't me
but no
you don't have guts I disagree Ukrainian
burn off like whoa whoa raise it I
understand why old goo so much I mean it
completely the touches you from the
guilt of your actions ah will you stop
shooting everything that looks pretty
funny oh it's [ __ ] hilarious
I love the confusing tone of the trailer
at first where it's like oh it's a
serious drama and it's an action movie
then you realize the punch line yeah two
entirely different brothers Sacha Baron
Cohen looks like he's created another
character totally Andy oh he's good he's
good at like creating you know like
keeping a sense of humor um you know
like there's tends to be vulgarity and
[ __ ] having a you know like all these
other different mannerisms as well and a
different type of accent as well yeah
which i think is hilarious absolutely no
like I love it I said and they got Mark
Strong as his brother and I think that's
a great Cassidy like what was with all
that casting like all of a sudden Gabor
Ystad BAE's in Italy what yeah I don't
know in Korea and yeah but I like this
director he's done a lot of films that I
really enjoyed is that the transporter
which I really like the transport to was
a blast
you know leash that was my favorite
American Jet Li film he did The
Incredible Hulk not King Lee's hope the
credible one he did now you see me and
he's done water yeah he's done a lot of
really entertaining films and yeah
what's cool is he tends to do action
films and this is a comedy with it but I
like John rakamma Dee's where yes it's a
comedy but they also honor as another
John Rowe which is action yeah I feel
like it's just gonna be a really
entertaining film and you know it's an
action comedy where the action seems
like it's really like thought out yeah
it looks like it's not just kind of
thrown in there to a piece of people
more than just a good trailer it like I
feel like the action genre the spy flick
will be fed will be felt I like seeing
that elements cool they got an action
director to do it yeah totally but
someone who seems like he's capable of
it with them
like now you see me which definitely had
a little bit of it was an action there's
no work to it you know he likes he knows
how to make exciting films he knows how
to make films that are fun to watch
exactly yeah and I feel like he's a
great director to collab with someone
like Sasha Baron Cohen yes yeah this is
gonna be another showcase for Sasha
Baron Cohen but I feel like they've got
another a bunch of other respectable
actors in there see this is actually a
movie I might see I usually don't dig
Sacha Baron Cohen I didn't like Bruno
and I never saw another one of his movie
I liked the dictator that was never
heard that was pretty funny and that was
scripted because I just don't like the
vulgarity so it just makes it makes
accessible you know but this one seems
like it has a little bit of that flavor
but maybe not too much yeah I might
actually go see it
oh yeah cuz like that one joke with like
sucking out the venom from the piece
that's when you're like okay
amber then I've heard that joke
punchline like told to me so many times
be uh it's like that's just too gross
that's your brother like come on
but that's what he likes that's his
style you know so I'm hoping that that
will be a little bit tempered but I know
a lot of people love that side of him
yeah you know it maybe maybe won't be a
phone for everyone I'm not a fan of
vulgarity I'm not a fan of crudeness I
like PG witty humor you ever done this
you know the two fingers and the thumb
at the same time that way you get the
thumb on the clitoris and then you're
just definitely the most PG thing I've
ever heard yeah like that yeah that's
pretty it's better to use these anyway
listen guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today become a reject
it'll be worth your [ __ ] time
Brianna White has a gaming channel plays
games on there don't call her a gamer
girl I've learned this lesson we'll do
one shout out one quick shot
ethan SROI hey Ryan I comment on heaps
of your vids and like all your vids I
would be stoked if I got a shout-out by
the way I love your vids you're amazing
and keep it up Ethan Troy my man you are
the boy whose ass I will destroy Oh
Ethan Troy sometimes you annoy with all
the comments that you leave below but
you know what one day you'll get a
Christmas toy that'll be a dildo ho I
lost it at the end yeah awesome you need
one more rhyme to cut it up tie that up
in a bow what it worked oh boy ahoy
Christmas merrimette joy there's there's
yeah okay we're done with the rhyming
ploy koi soy huh yeah boy uh I said
annoyingly anymore Leonard yeah